d'abord on n'est rien ou presque rien et
puis des deux on devient un alpiniste
primitif accroché à une membrane
cellulaire
telle une falaise fragiles pour pouvoir
exister
et puis un monitoring annonce notre
venue au monde 1,6 accès mais a sursauté
créant de relief
celle annonce de notre arrivée au monde
monitoring swing del corazon salsa
passants et puis notre premier envol un
saut en arrière vertigineux pour ses
maîtres à flotter dans les airs d'un air
liquide qui vous invite à la vie ratée
et puis il ya la 1ère plate figure
scientifique de votre identité
on a tous au droit
c'est comme notre première photo
d'identité un canular qui casse le rêve
et heureusement je fais c'est là nous
donnera la chance d'être ce que nous
devons s'être est pas le rêve des
quelqu'un mais l'idéal qui ne s'enchaîne
ray ça nous laissera la chance d'être ce
que nous devons être
et là le premier regard par la science
interposés qui veut déjà asseoir son
savoir sur nos premiers regards de la
mère et de père à son enfant
on commence donc tous par se coltiner
une identité une fausse identité
scientifique il faudra choisir et s'en
saisir dès notre chance de vivre
on est d'accord qui s'est fait refuge
pour nom ça celle qui vous porte le c
non on le sait pas on perd beaucoup de
temps à savoir qu'ils launay qui et
l'ona une existence après on sera même
en temps de même beaucoup je trouve même
quand on sera expulsé de se vendre en
pousser à vivre on sera sans commune
mais sur des sans logis
très tôt la seule boussole dans ces
milieux là que nous savons et qu'elle
nous serons c'est respirer
on aura encore mais on sera quoi faire
de lui
il fera toujours à sa guise moi j'étais
poussée poussée de naître pressé de
naître peut-être comme tout mexicaine
qui se respecte j'ai voulu très tôt
découdre avec la vie jouer ma partie
avec la mort ma mère me rends compte m'a
raconté ce qui s'est joué dans cette
première rencontre avant de vraiment
méconnaître et l'a fallu qu'elle reste
six mois allongé
je lui imposer la mobilité et la
septaine le défi dès ma naissance
hélas resté six mois allongé un
supportant cette immobilité s'est mis en
mobilité que je lui un poste après elle
se rattrapera
elle m'a dit que j'ai failli pas naître
et que l'invention que la rue pour que
je puisse être là c'est déjouer une
autre deux parties de jambes en l'air
drôle d'invention mais cette fois elle
sol avec son corps donc elle a passé le
temps de mettre les jambes en l'air pour
que mes forces et à rester dedans et que
je attend le temps de naître vraiment et
puis
mais voilà ça marchait première fille
naît de ce corps de femme
la quatrième est la première fille l'a
fait dire mariana c'était une fête
c'était joyeux
je pense que c'est un la jeter hors us
dans le bras de ma mère dans les yeux de
mon père enfin je ne sais rien on est
tous au départ c'est qui on nous raconte
que nous sommes mon père a dit ma mère a
dit il sont dits jacques a dit moi j'ai
rien dit
un jour après une court repos c est
arrivé alors ceux qui étaient ces six
axes festive et joyeux de départ est
devenue une pique une cassure vers le
bas c'est la fée et causé une fracture
une facture un mois et dans les autres
membres de ma famille quelque chose a
marqué le drôle de cette rencontre avec
ce petit être kenney aussi de ce corps
dis donc il fait des drôles de choses
ces montres là c'est là surgit dans mon
horizon qui commençait à être une
prairie qui commençait à ces fleurir de
marguerite de être de ne pas s'être même
même pas une autre naissance donc de son
corps fait irruption et pour moi la
chute dans l'abyme la naissance des
petits silence et des terreurs naissante
le premier souvenir que j'ai d'elle
c'est un berceau silencieux des images
plates coller dans le mur adossé à ce
berceau qui lahti attendu comme un mois
il y avait des mères heureuse avec leur
bébé dans les bras
mais dans ce berceau y avait un chiffon
un bébé chiffon presque qui était pas là
comme os ils n'étaient pas nés pour moi
le différence le mystère de la
différence était couché là et moi
j'étais sidéré c'est là a commencé à
créer le creux de la vague
quelque chose s'est mis à mais cros et
c'était un corps étrange mais elle comme
moi elle a réussit mal que bien agrandir
à vivre mais plus rien autour était
pareil
personne dans ma famille plus de fait
plus des marianne avait la noche comme
on m'avait appelé ma mère à cause d'une
telenovela mexicaine en vogue ces temps
là plus rien aussi les tout d'une autre
chose envers ses sauts dans le temps
autre relief autres courbes et autres
virages et un jour le réveil fort c'est
la réalité qui met casse un peu un coup
dans la gueule
j'ai reçu de ma soeur avec sa jambe
cette de jambes encore
elle m'a donné ce coup dans la figure si
fort qu'elle met délogea de la voiture
dans laquelle on s'apprêtait toute la
famille à partir dans la ville voisine
des roises caliente et ce au mexique
je suis resté là par terre mon cul par
terre on être cassé en deux je pense que
c'est vraiment ce jour où je suis né
parce que c'est le premier pourquoi qui
est né à moi avant je vivais dans un
rêve cauchemar qui ne m'appartenait pas
ce jour j'ai su que dans mon corps
pouvaient s'est logée l'innommable
l'incompréhensible personnes est venue
mais médée mais relevé personnes à condé
ma soeur pour lui dire l'inscrire dans
ce loi lui dire que ça c'était pas
possible j'ai dû encore on voit mais
décidé à n'être jamais relevé
mais il y avait une fissure à moi j'ai
dû donc apprendre à faire avec cette
fissure et avec ses blessures et avec ma
soeur autiste être la soeur où les
parents ont le fils d'une personne
autiste
ça vous tombe dessus on n'a pas choisi
''cela veut parfois vous définir vous
dire qui vous êtes mais à l'autiste la
personne autiste ça lui tombent aussi
déçu il tire le gros lot c'est un coup
aussi dans la gueule mais elle s'est
encore plus invisible elle c'est le
coltinera je le savais pas elle devra se
coltiner savin sa vie collé à la figure
je veux alors vous parlez de cette
rencontre
cette rencontre que j'ai eue qu'il y a
que d'autres ont vu entre le centre
normand lé pa normand avec les fous les
différents une rencontre entre et la
platitude de la norme et les reliefs de
l'indifférence les parents savent très
bien témoigner de ce qui a été sa pour
comment pour moi une sidération un arrêt
une fracture une cassure
la rencontre impromptue qui tue mais qui
vous force changement si vous le voulez
bien
c'est là vous force si vous le décidez à
être laissée sculpteur de la cassure oui
c'est vrai au départ cloud a été
communiquée à une irruption dérangeante
une fryer quelque chose qui a fait une
rupture mais nous avons eu la chance de
vouloir nous sape rave apprivoiser l'une
à l'autre
parce que je pense qu'il faut quand même
un manque chez ceux chez nous et ça on
l'avait à partager une été pareil elle
avait peut-être quelque chose à moi moi
aussi avec sa naissance j'ai eu encore
quelque chose à moi mais c'est là qu'on
a décidé avec le vide qui nous savons
tous à nous pour que les pourquoi elle
est comment puissent se loger quelque
part il faut bien un vide et ce manque
il faut savoir y faire avec mais avec sa
naissance aussi elle a créé de nouvelles
variations on s'est amusé à vouloir
remplir le vide et l'une dans le vide de
l'autre c'est une illusion
vous moi ne le savons j'espère que vous
le savez on réussit jamais à vis à
remplir le vide
et puis notre naissance ni le vide quel
autre a laissé un nous c'est une chimère
je voudrais donc si vous transmettre la
valeur de l'infini de la différence des
cr lief des touches c'est s'être qui ont
quelque chose à moi mais pourquoi pas un
plus ça dépend comment vous voulez le
voir
soit le vert émond à moitié vide soit il
est à moitié plein oui elle était une
frayeur pour moi et les parents le
savent aussi
mais les parents que j'ai rencontré les
deux les autres personnes qui ont
quelques quelqu'un qui est différent
aucun bras
contre la différence en soi même nous
disent comment au départ il s'était
sidérait primark cette sidération de
laquelle il faut décider de sortir des
s'est bougé le ton qu'elle avait ce
qu'est elle a vraiment respect réveiller
la curiosité à moi elle a eu le don de
m'intriguer donc j'ai voulu laisser une
place pour elle un mois peut-être que
finalement rencontrer l'autre différents
fours pas c'est vouloir remplir ses
creux c'est qui c'est cross and au delà
différents jouets on peut accepter le
vite l'un dans l'autre
mais le mans qui m'a aidé c'est un mot
donné par ma mère c'est celui qui m'a
aidé à sortir de cette sidération
un jour elle m'a dit elle avait trouvé
une description d'une fille mutique
qu'on avait appelé la rosa azul alors
est venu avec ce petit papier et elle
m'a dit tu sais ta soeur elle est comme
une ressembles rare est différent unique
comme tout le comme aucune alors j'ai su
que j'avais la chance finalement d'avoir
qui est très peu entré non nous avons la
chance d'avoir quelqu'un des six
différents alors je me suis sentie senti
responsable des marots si vous
connaissez cette chanson plutôt cette
histoire
les parents de l'association de laquelle
fait partie avec beaucoup de fierté le
savent mieux que moi
nous on a dû apprendre avec la
bizarrerie de l'autre sinon nous savons
la combattre ça pourrait être une triste
guerre
nous nous voulons battre ça faire avec
l'autisme de l'autre avec cette partie
innommable
c'est d'abord accepté donc le vide le
vide vivre le vide d avoir un creux à
l'intérieur de soi et c'est aussi
trouver un nom pour cela comme c'était
le cas pour pour ma mère
cloud ya je pense qu'il a donnée de
relier femmes à vis ma vie sans sel
maintenant je trouve ça serait plate et
ennuyeuse elle m'a appris à prendre et
avaient observé les petites choses elle
elle est beaucoup observé les fourmis
alors je me suis inventé une place avec
elle je me suis assis à côté d'elle à
observer les fourmis et elle m'a appris
le valeur la grandeur de petites choses
parce que ces gens-là nous apprennent à
voir ce qui nous ne savons pas voir nous
ne savons pas regarder les parents de la
main l'oreille on a fait le pari de nous
inventer une vie avec eux mais pas pour
qu'il ressemble à nous mêmes mais pour
la partager
pour aller dans un monde ensemble à
gravir ces fissures et ses cassures qui
parfois nous font glisser nous font
tomber mais on monte avec eux on
s'accroche et on y va parce que nous ne
voulons pas qu'il soit pareil à ne
s'arrêteront à nyon nous avons fait le
pari de l'invention
parce que quand on le fait le risque est
seulement découvrir un an un horizon
infini avec des sauteurs fantastique maé
et une sauce servent de quoi je parle
parfois on peut coc très haut et
regarder presque les six toiles bon je
pense que j'espère vous avoir transmis
ce qui a été pour moi cette deuxième
naissance avec ma soeur et avec tous les
parents de la main à l'oreille que
maintenant j'ai rencontré parce que nous
pensons que nous savons tous les droits
d'être ce que nous sommes nous avons
appris et pris le risque au coeur et au
corps de relief de prend le relief
et vous savez quoi finalement la norme
n'est pas la plus belle
il faut la jeter à la poubelle je vous
laisse découvrir la mention de cesse
être là
non
à
ans
on